المرشح الجمهوري لرئاسه مجلس النواب
الامريكي زعيم الاغلبيه في المجلس كفن
مكاري فشل في الفوز بالرئاسه وذلك بعد 13
جوله من التصويت انتهت قبل قليل
14 صوتا اضافيا مقارنه بالجولات ال 11
السابقه فانه اخفى قائدا في الحصول على
2818 صوتا تلزم لفوزه برئاسه المجلسا وصوت
سبعه نواب من اقصى يمين الحزب الجمهوري ضد
مانشستر
ومعنا الان مباشره من امام الكونغرس
مراسلاتنا بيسان ابو كويك بيسان
اليبدو ان الموضوع مستمر جوله الثالثه
عشره
والفشل كان نصيبها ما الذي نتوقعه الان
المجلس صوت قبل قليل على تاجيل اعماله حتى
الساعه العاشره مساء بالتوقيت المحلي
السادسه صباحا بتوقيت الدوحه لجوله
التصويت رابعه عشر ولكن ااه هناك اخبار
جيده لمقار في اليوم اليوم مختلف ربما عن
الايام التي سبقت اليوم امنا 15 صوتا من
معارضيه هذه انفراج كبيره وزخم كبير همم
لمقارسي الان ما زال هناك الست اصوات فقط
وهم كنا نتحدث عنهم من الرافدين جمله
وتفصيلا لمقرتي لذا الاستراتيجيه الحاليه
ومقاره يتحدث للصحفيين قبل قليل يقول انه
واثق من ان لديه الاصوات المطلوبه الليله
لتامين رئاسه المجلس طبعا لا نعلم لان
قضايا الحسابات وهمم والمشادات السياسيه
خلف الابواب
ليست ولم يكن الطريق ممهد همم له منذ
البدايه ولكن ما نتوقعه الليله هناك عدوان
جمهوريان كان قد غادر واشنطن مما يقلل
السقف وافقد مقارتي صوتين سيعودان الى
واشنطن في وقت لاحق الليله للتصويت له من
ما سيجلب اصواته الى 216 لذا سيطر مقار في
خلالها هذه الساعات بانتظار جوله التصوير
المقبله نحو ست ساعات تفصلنا عنها الى
اقناع عضوين من السته المعارضين للتصويت
لصالحه ويبدو انه واثق من ذلك ولكن طبعا
الامور دائما تتغير هنا في الكوندس وتتغير
في واشنطن لكن ايضا المهم جدا ان نلفت
اليه الى ان مقال فيه قدم لهذه المجموعه
المعارضه وهي من قد تجمع الحريه اليمين
جدا هنا قدم الكثير من التنازلات حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يوجد اعلان رسمه عن ماهيه
التنازلات ولكن هناك قلق البعض لكن ذلك لن
يؤثر على الارجح على النتيجه النهائيه مما
قدم لهم ومن تداعيات ذلك على كيفيه حكم
الجمهوريين لمجلس النواب اا في الاشهر
المقبله تنازلات متعلقه بسحب الثقه من
مكائن من مكارثي او من رئيس المجلس يعني
الذي سينتقل تخفيض
الى مشرع واحد بامكانه التقدم بصحب الثقه
قضيه اخرى لها علاقه بصقف الدين يبدو انه
اعطى ضمانات بحرب همم متعلقه برفع سقف
الدين وهو امر مقبل في وقت لاحق من هذا
العام هو هو امر سيؤثر على الاقتصاد
الامريكي برمته هذه المجموعه هي محافظه
جده
اقتصاديه واجتماعيا وما الى ذلك لذا قضيه
الانفاق كانت من الامور التي كانت تهتم
بها همم كان هناك حديث عن وعود بتخفيض
موازنه وزاره الدفاع بخمسه وسبعين مليار
دولار وهذا امر قد يغضب ايضا من داخل
الحزب الجمهوري لذا مقرتي تقدم بالكثير من
التنازلات ولكن يبدو ان ذلك لم يفقده اي
اصوات من تلك الكتله التي كانت تؤيدها منذ
البدايه لان الجميع يريد انهاء هذه الازمه
حتى لو جلبت صعوبات
لمقارسي وللقياد الجمهوريه في حكم المجلس
في الاشهر المقبله
يعني بعد كل هذا 13 جوله فشل حتى الان على
العموم اشكرك لسانك من الكونجرس وربما همم
لا ادري